这是Al Brooks 和 module 4 上的市场费用程序
今天我会谈谈论人权的设计
大家 familiar with the list of trades
多数设计的设计
一些设计很明显
设计方法 设计方法 设计方法
两个设计上的设计
最重要的是 设计方法 设计方法
和设计方法
设计方法 设计方法
他们不曾说过 可能这次会有效
我会试试 或者说 可能我会试试
他们没有试试的设计
因为市场有些设计
那些设计会有效
他们会谈谈论人权
如果设计方法不像他们平常设计
如果是不太对的设计
他们就不设计 他们就让它进行
设计方法 设计方法
他们不曾说过 可能这次会有效
我会试试 或者说 可能我会试试
他们没有试试设计
因为市场有些设计
那些设计会有效
他们的设计方法 设计方法
如果是不太对的设计
或者是不太对的设计
他们就不设计 他们就要进行
设计方法 设计方法
对于 computer 设计
他们要调整他们的设计
设计方法 设计方法
设计方法
如果要做些什么
设计方法 设计方法
Mheartmm me
lados
Arab
but top
unable
no
more
creat Phillip
市场能做正确的反应
记住,任何时候你拿出费
一个人的职业率也同时
另一个人的职业率也同时
你不能太确定
在其他地方的职业率是错的
那些职业率,无论你如何确定
是会在一时至40%的时间
如果你是一个很好的职业率
你可能会在一时至40%的时间失去
你必须要坐在那里做什么
如果你是一个很好的职业率
你必须要坐在一时至三
等待一个好职业率
不要太惊讶
然后说自己的职业率是错的
可能会在这一时失去职业率
一个好职业率是不错的
所以有些职业率
会在一时至30%的时间失去职业率
可能会在一时至3-4%的时间失去职业率
如果你想去结束职业率
在最后一天
你必须要在市场上
与职业率相同
如果职业率很少
你必须要坐在那里
休息一会
这很重要
就是在不幸的情况下
无论你发生的职业率
有时有不幸的职业率
第一个很明显的职业率
是
会不会在职业率上成功
你必须要在职业率上成功
在你的目标上成功
然后你必须要在职业率上成功
在你使用你的职业率
你必须要在职业率上成功
比如说2点在Emini
可能50%在IBM
或是你必须要用一个大小的 stop
或是小小的 stop
你必须要在职业率上成功
如果职业率很大
而且职业率很大
你必须要在职业率上成功
而这就是
职业率在这一段时间之中
如果你自己在受苦
或有心
或有心的
你没有时间
你不要行动
因为你感觉有心
你不可以 make money
如果心有心
是在发生你的決心
因为你正在做
什么东西
而且他们不在职业率上成功
有心
你必须要在职业率上成功
他们要来
如果你是一个很好的职业率
你必须要在职业率上成功
有40%的时间
如果你是职业率上成功
没有什么是 crystal clear
的
如果你是觉得有什么是 crystal clear
不要在职业率上成功
因为你正在在职业率上成功
最后一天
你把策划出了
所有东西都是 crystal clear
但这不是真的
有时有必要的
你必须要在职业率上成功
如果这是你的工作
和你在职业率上成功
我已经在职业率上成功
有40%的时间
但我已经很难受
我已经很难受
你能做得更多的钱吗
肯定
但你必须要在职业率上成功
有好多年
如果你是
在职业率上成功
那是不
最好的方法
你必须要在职业率上成功
有时间很 precious
每一部分你的生活都应该有趣
你能够
做得更多的钱
而
在职业率上成功
有很多工作
你能够真的爱你
做得更多的钱
职业率上成功
你必须要在职业率上成功
有很多方法
做得更多的钱
职业率上成功
你必须要在职业率上成功
但有4个货币
2个3个
比他们的危害
如果他们有足够
只能赢40%
那是很好的方法
其实是最好的方法
职业率上成功
其他职业率上成功
是很方便
职业率上成功
所以如果市场
在一周的货币上
他们会在高高的
比较高的高
如果他们有信心
职业率上成功
或是连续
但他们必须要有
更多的货币
职业率上成功
他们必须要有
信心
他们必须要有信心
那些货币
就是他们必须要有信心
他们必须要有信心
对面的语言
但是每次
有些货币
所有的货币
只会在下午
所以货币
也许
如果你带着小货币
你必须保持
你的货币的运动力
是比你的货币的比例
如果你带着小货币
比你的货币的运动力
你必须带着80%-90%的时间
很难做的
有些货币的运动力
有任何阻挡
高可能性 低可能性
脚踏 踏
踏 踏 踏
那是可以的
如果你是货币的运动力
你必须带着你货币的运动力
你必须带着
货币的运动力
是最重要的一部分
比币的运动力
更重要的
货币的运动力
是非常容易的
但是很难做
货币的运动力
才能做得到
很多时候
货币的运动力
是很长的
所以很多时候
在每一天的时间
你能买货币
如果你货币的运动力
怎么办
说你货币
有一个人在货币的运动力
你会有一个更好的方法
去付钱
但是
是货币的运动力
你必须做得好
所以
就像我刚刚说的
在任何一个货币的运动力
可以付钱
如果他们货币的运动力
是对的
这是最后的
谢谢